ahora que ya vimos un repaso sobre
oxidación y reducción veamos si podemos
aplicar lo que ya sabemos a la
respiración celular vamos a ver en la
respiración celular por cada molde
glucosa que es 66 h 12 o 6 que puede
estar en solución acuosa está disuelto
en agua podemos combinar esto con 6
moles de oxígeno molecular y así las
células pueden realizar la respiración
celular mediante una serie de pasos se
realiza la respiración celular y
terminamos con 6 moles de dióxido de
carbono
necesitamos inhalar este oxígeno para
que se realice la respiración celular y
así exhalamos el dióxido de carbono que
es un subproducto de la respiración
celular entonces tenemos 6 moles de
dióxido de carbono y 6 moles de agua y
el objetivo de la respiración celular es
que obtenemos esto
y un poco de energía se produce energía
en esta reacción y nuestros cuerpos
almacenan esta energía bueno una parte
se transforma en calor pero el objetivo
principal de la respiración celular es
almacenar esa energía en 38 atp que ya
vimos que es la moneda de los sistemas
biológicos nuestros cuerpos o cualquier
sistema biológico en general pueden usar
estos atp para contraer los músculos o
generar impulsos nerviosos o para que
las células crezcan o se dividan o para
lo que sea que necesite hacer el sistema
biológico ahora en el vídeo anterior
aprendimos un poco sobre oxidación y
reducción entonces apliquemos esas ideas
aquí en el vídeo anterior vimos que un
químico diría lo escribiré de esta
manera un químico diría que la oxidación
significa perder electrones no se los
pueden quedar
electrones mientras que para la
reducción un químico nos diría que la
reducción es ganar electrones ganar
electrones y si les cuesta trabajo solo
recuerden que la oxidación es perder
electrones si quieren pueden usar la
mnemotecnia pero perder electrones es
oxidación y ganar electrones es
reducción pueden usar here help eso es
lo que aprenden en una clase de química
pero miren los biólogos o los
bioquímicos dirían bueno ya sabes me
gusta definirlo un poco diferente vamos
a escribirlo así un biólogo diría que la
oxidación es perder perder átomos de
hidrógeno de hidrógeno y que la
reducción es ganar átomos de hidrógeno
ganar átomos de hidrógeno y en el vídeo
anterior vimos que esta definición es un
poco difícil cuando tratamos de
aplicarla al hidrógeno molecular porque
el átomo de hidrógeno
no se puede perder o ganar a sí mismo y
la razón por la que dijimos que estas
dos ideas son consistentes es porque si
hablamos de un carbono y un carbono
pierde un hidrógeno por ejemplo si
tenemos un compuesto como este que tal
vez está conectado a un montón de otras
cosas pero supongamos que también
tenemos un oxígeno unido o tal vez a
otro oxígeno y tal vez este oxígeno está
unido a algo más solo por decir pero si
con esto es con lo que empezamos y del
otro lado de la reacción terminamos con
algo que se ve así en donde el carbono
está unido a un oxígeno y tal vez el
otro oxígeno está unido a este hidrógeno
bueno los biólogos dirían o este carbono
se ha oxidado porque perdió un hidrógeno
verdad el hidrógeno se movió de este
carbono a este oxígeno y los biólogos
también dirían que este oxígeno se ha
reducido se ha reducido porque ganó un
litro
pero la realidad es que la definición de
los químicos que es en lo personal me
gusta un poco más es que como el carbono
es más electro negativo miren aquí
podemos ver que el carbono es más
electro negativo que el hidrógeno y a su
vez el oxígeno es más electro negativo
que el carbono cuando algunos de estos
elementos está unido al hidrógeno
acaparan los electrones entonces aquí el
carbono acapara los electrones el
carbono acapara los electrones mientras
que aquí los electrones son acaparados
por el oxígeno el oxígeno acapara así
que al perder un hidrógeno el carbono
pierde su oportunidad de acaparar los
electrones y como el hidrógeno termina
unido al oxígeno el carbono no solamente
no puede acaparar los electrones del
hidrógeno sino que además sus propios
electrones son acaparados por un átomo
más electro negativo
es que estas dos definiciones son
consistentes y lo mismo ocurre con el
oxígeno miren aquí está unido a otro
oxígeno no acapara nada pero cuando gana
un hidrógeno puede acaparar los
electrones que comparte con el hidrógeno
porque es mucho más electro negativo y
simplemente podemos decir que gana
electrones por eso es que de alguna
manera estas dos definiciones son
consistentes aunque algunas veces no
funcionan sino estamos trabajando con
hidrógeno por un lado la definición
química aplica más a todos los casos
pero por el otro la definición de los
biólogos es más fácil de encontrar en
los libros pero bueno regresemos a la
respiración celular y tratemos de saber
qué es lo que se oxida y qué es lo que
se reduce vamos a ver aquí tenemos a la
glucosa y aquí he puesto la molécula que
copié de wikipedia esta es una molécula
de glucosa aunque tiene un error porque
aquí falta otro hidrógeno unido a ese
carbono
aquí todos los hidrógenos están unidos
ya sea a un oxígeno o a un carbono
entonces del lado izquierdo todos los
hidrógenos están unidos a un oxígeno o a
un carbono y si escribimos su estado de
oxidación en cada caso un hidrógeno está
unido a algo que es más electro negativo
por lo tanto dona sus electrones tiene
un estado de oxidación de uno más y el
oxígeno en cada caso está unido a un
carbono oa un hidrógeno
entonces si el oxígeno está unido a un
carbono oa un hidrógeno acapara los
electrones que comparte con cualquiera
de ellos así que en la glucosa
el oxígeno tiene un estado de oxidación
de 2 - ok y en el caso del carbono como
toda la molécula es neutra podemos
pensar que el carbono tiene un estado de
oxidación neutro porque miren si
analizamos esto podemos ver que la
mayoría de estos carbonos tienen
estados de oxidación neutros voy a
circular algunos por ejemplo este
carbono acá para el electrón de este
hidrógeno pero uno de sus electrones es
acaparado por el oxígeno y claro eso no
le hace nada al carbono así que es
neutro y este carbono también es neutro
por la misma razón
éste también es neutro por la misma
razón y éste también porque aunque está
unido a dos carbonos uno de sus
electrones es acaparado por el oxígeno
pero a su vez acapara el electrón del
hidrógeno así que es neutro entonces 4
carbonos de esta molécula son neutros
pero este carbono tiene 2 electrones
acaparados por 2 oxígenos y sólo acapara
uno del hidrógeno así que tiene un
estado de oxidación de más 1 y en este
caso ocurre lo contrario el carbono
acapara los electrones de los dos
hidrógenos pero tiene que darle uno de
sus electrones al oxígeno entonces éste
tiene un necesitado de
oxidación de -1 y así los dos se
cancelan entonces podemos decir que los
carbonos de la glucosa tienen un estado
de oxidación neutro y hasta ahí estamos
trabajando con la definición química
pero acuérdense que las dos definiciones
son equivalentes y miren aquí los dos
oxígenos tienen un estado de oxidación
neutro porque como están unidos con un
doble enlace al otro oxígeno no acapara
nada tienen la misma electro negatividad
ok y si analizamos los productos el
dióxido de carbono se ve así por lo que
en cualquiera de los dos casos el
oxígeno acaparados electrones del carbón
así que tiene un estado de oxidación de
2 - y este oxígeno también acapara 2
electrones del carbono así que tiene un
estado de oxidación de 2 - y como este
carbono pierde todos sus electrones de
valencia porque todos sus electrones son
acaparados por los oxígenos tienen
estado de oxidación de 4 más podemos
imaginar que pierde sus 4 electrones
entonces en el carbono podemos escribir
4 más y cada oxígeno tiene un estado de
oxidación de 2 - ok y finalmente si
analizamos el agua el oxígeno acaparados
electrones entonces escribimos 2 - por
lo tanto cada hidrógeno tiene un estado
de oxidación de uno más y si analizamos
las reacciones parciales de la
respiración celular que en términos
químicos es analizar el movimiento de
los electrones podemos decir bueno
empezamos con 12 hidrógenos de este lado
vamos a escribirlo así tenemos h 12 de
este lado y todos tienen un estado de
oxidación de uno más y después de que
ocurre la respiración celular también
tenemos 12 hidrógenos pero vamos a
escribirlo un poco diferente y
nuevamente cada hidrógeno tiene
estado de oxidación de uno más así que
desde el punto de vista de oxidación y
reducción no le pasa nada al hidrógeno
pero ahora si analizamos el carbono del
lado izquierdo de la reacción tenemos 6
carbonos y todos tienen un estado de
oxidación neutro pero después que pasa
del lado derecho bueno también tenemos 6
carbonos pero escritos un poco diferente
aquí tenemos 6 carbonos y cada uno tiene
un estado de oxidación de 4 más lo que
significa que cada uno perdió 4
electrones al perder 4 electrones que
sabemos que están cargados negativamente
el estado de oxidación es 4 más así que
después de la respiración celular
terminamos con 6 carbonos con un estado
de oxidación de 4 + más y como cada uno
pierde 4 electrones y tenemos 64 por 6
en total son 24 electrones
estos son los electrones que pierde el
carbón así que en la respiración celular
el carbono es oxidado recuerden la
oxidación es la pérdida de electrones
entonces en la respiración celular al
analizar la reacción parcial los 6
carbonos pierden 24 electrones en total
ok y finalmente si analizamos el oxígeno
vamos a ver estos 6 oxígenos del lado
izquierdo tienen un estado de oxidación
de 2 - entonces vamos a ponerlo así y
tienen un estado de oxidación de 2 - y
después tenemos estos 12 oxígenos que
son completamente neutros vamos a
ponerlos esos 12 oxígenos son neutros
así que no escribimos ningún estado de
oxidación ok y después qué pasa cuando
ocurre la respiración celular bueno en
el dióxido de carbono tenemos 12
oxígenos con un estado de oxidación
2 - 62 vamos a escribir del dióxido de
carbono tenemos 62 con un estado de
oxidación de 2 - y después tenemos otros
6 oxígenos que también tienen un estado
de oxidación de 2 - entonces más 6
oxígenos con un estado de oxidación de 2
- ok y si lo pensamos un poco aquí en
total tenemos una carga de menos 12 6
por menos 2 y aquí tenemos 6 por menos 2
que nuevamente es menos 12 pero después
otra vez tenemos 6 por menos 2 por 2
porque son dos átomos y eso es menos 24
entonces al pasar de menos 12 hasta una
carga total de menos 36 debemos ganar 24
electrones y miren esos 24 electrones
que ganan los oxígenos son los mismos 24
electrones que los carbonos pierde
desde el punto de vista químico es muy
claro el carbono fue oxidado y el
oxígeno que ganó estos electrones ger
gana electrones el que es reducido el
oxígeno es reducido todo esto es un
repaso pero es bueno verlo en el
contexto de la respiración celular y de
hecho esto nos explica de dónde proviene
esta energía y en cualquiera de estas
reacciones químicas cuando se produce
energía es porque los electrones pasan
de un estado de mayor energía a uno de
menor energía por ejemplo si tenemos un
electrón que se encuentra aquí en un
estado de mayor energía mayor y pasa a
un estado más cómodo de menor energía
aquí hay un estado de energía más
estable bueno este cambio libera energía
en forma de calor o incluso puede
producir un trabajo que de alguna manera
ayude a formar las moléculas de atp
entonces cuando nos encontramos con
estas reacciones parciales en la
que se pierden 24 electrones por el
carbono el carbono es oxidado porque
esos electrones se van con el oxígeno
claro aunque eso ocurre en varios pasos
no todo de golpe todo esto ocurre en una
serie de pasos y conforme estos
electrones pasan a estados de menor
energía especialmente al pasar de los
carbonos hacia los oxígenos de ahí se
obtiene la energía para producir 38
moléculas de atp así que hasta ahora
hemos hablado un poco sobre como los
químicos ven la oxidación y al principio
del vídeo vimos como es que los biólogos
ven la oxidación y después vimos que la
respiración celular desde el punto de
vista químico claramente demuestra que
el carbono es oxidado porque pierde
electrones y que el oxígeno es reducido
gana electrones los electrones pasan de
este carbono a estos oxígenos que
tenemos aquí
cómo es que la definición de los
biólogos respalda todo esto bueno en
realidad lo explica bastante bien miren
podemos imaginar que aquí todos los
hidrógenos están asociados a la glucosa
entonces si analizamos la estructura de
la glucosa podemos ver que los
hidrógenos están unidos ya sea a
carbonos oa oxígenos verdad entonces
estos hidrógenos están unidos a carbonos
y oxígeno y si nos vamos al lado derecho
de la reacción todos los hidrógenos
están unidos únicamente al oxígeno así
que definitivamente el carbono pierde
todos los hidrógenos y el oxígeno gana
esos hidrógenos vamos a escribir en la
respiración celular el carbono pierde
hidrógenos pierde hidrógeno y el oxígeno
gana hidrógenos
el oxígeno gana hidrógenos y eso es
consistente porque ya vimos que desde el
punto de vista de un biólogo algo que
pierde hidrógeno se dice que es oxidado
y por el contrario al ganar hidrógenos
en este caso el oxígeno es reducido y
bueno este proceso de transferir los
hidrógenos es facilitado por moléculas
como el n además y el f ate pero por el
momento solo queremos comprender que los
hidrógenos son transferidos de un átomo
electro negativo a otro y lo que
realmente se transfiere es la
oportunidad de acaparar electrones si el
carbono está unido al hidrógeno puede
acaparar los electrones pero si el
hidrógeno todo el átomo de hidrógeno
pasa al oxígeno
ahora el oxígeno gana ese electrón que
puede acaparar mientras que el carbono
perdió ese electrón así que el carbono
es oxidado y el oxígeno es reducido
probablemente lo más confuso sobre la
oxidación es que siempre queremos decir
seguramente tiene algo que ver con el
oxígeno y en parte sí pero la oxidación
en realidad quiere decir que le hizo el
oxígeno a algo entonces cuando el
oxígeno se une a algo le quita sus
electrones o en una reacción
generalmente quita los hidrógenos en
este caso le quitó los hidrógenos al
carbón de ahí que se le llame oxidación
aunque en realidad no tenemos que tener
oxígeno en la reacción para que ocurra
la oxidación o la reducción entonces
espero que esto les sirva esto fue muy
complicado para mí cuando me lo
enseñaron porque a mí me gusta más la
definición química de oxidación y
reducción y de pronto al estudiar
biología cuando nos hablaron de perder y
ganar hidrógenos en lugar de electrones
me costó un poco entender las dos
nociones